مع دكتوره هبه عمر
الرئيسه اللجنه التمهيديه لنقابه اطباء
السودان مرحبا بك دكتوره معنا اذا كان لكم
بيان متعلق بضروره السماح
باجلاء المصابين والمرضى ما هو الواقع
لديكم بالنسبه ايضا لاعداد الاصابات وحتى
من قتل في الساعات الماضيه
السلاموريات
حروب
وعادل الشفاء
اول خلينا نوجه نداء عاجل لوقف الحرب
والاحتكام بصوت العاشق
واعلام الوطن
المواطن البريد
المواطنين البريئين
كافه المنظمات الانسانيه العامله بالسودان
والحركه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر والهلال
الاحمر بده من اجل الاخلاص الطبي واسعاف
الجنحه والمصابين والاحتباسات الداميه
الدائره الان في الخرطوم في شوارع الخرطوم
واثقه الخرطوم وفي مدن السودان الاخرى بين
فؤاد الدعم السريع وقوات الجيش
العديد من الجهداء من الشهداء والجرحى
والمصابين جاري حشرهم حتى الان في
تحديث للاصابات المؤكده لاعداد الشهداء
والجرحى من المستشفيات
بيصير في صفحه
المساعده في التوفير عندنا مقتدير في
المحاليل الوريديه واكياس الدم والمعينات
الطبيه والادويه في الحياه في
بالنسبه
للتواصلك تواصلكم مع الجهات المعنيه هل
هنالك يعني قنوات تواصل هذه المناشده يعني
تم اطلاقها وكما قلت الاحصاءات تحدث عبر
منصاتكم لكن هل هناك قنوات تواصل مع اي من
الجهات
لاجلاء المصابين
لوصول المستلزمات الطبيه للمرضى
المناسبه
وصلنا لعدد من تواصلت معانا عدد من
القنوات
العربيه
وتم المناسبه ايضا هنالك مناسبه مستمره في
صفحاتنا والفيسبوك هل هي صفحه اللجنه
التمهيديه لنقابه اطباء ولكن لا تجد
استجابه حقيقه حتى الان نحن موديلين انه
الاشتباكات شديده جدا والان ثقه للطائرات
للدانات والذخيره وباسلحه صغيره لكن
بنتمنى انه يتم التواصل مع الاطراف
المستنزعه لايجاد ممرات العبور
لاجلاء الجرحى والمصابين وعبور الكوادر
الصحيه والمعينات
برضه فيها مصابين من الدعم السريع والجيش
فيها مصابين من الاطراف المتقاتله ولكن
بعضها ايضا هو يقع في في منطقه عمليات
يعني
التبعات وجود هذه المستشفيات مثلا قربى
قرب القياده العامه او في المناطق التي
تجري فيها
المواجهات ما هي يعني هذه المستشفيات
وطبيعه عملها التي تبدو محاصره
حقيقه هي كل الالعاب
العاصمه المثلثه هي المنطقه بتاعه عمليات
ما في مرفق الحرب بالشوارع
نعم اذا اذا استطعتم اجلاء المصابين من
هذه المنطقه كما قلت هي منطقه عمليات كلها
يعني اي المناطق في السودان التي بالامكان
ان تقوم به وتقدم خدمات طبيه للمصابين او
حتى للمرضى خلاف المناطق التي يجري فيها
القتال
انا
عفوا انا مع اخي انت سؤالك لكن في
مستشفيات حاليا في الخدمه لكن الخدمه اللي
بتقدمها
بالنسبه
للحنكيات اللي انا قلتها في نقطه كوادر
الطبيه والمعينات
شغاله في شرق النيل
في بحري في المستشفى الدولي في الخرطوم
يمكن اغلب المستطيلات مستشفى الجوده برضه
كبير جدا
عدد من المستشفيات ايضا في مستشفى وعد
والاربعين ومستشفى ام درمان مستشفى بحري
اله والفاشر ويحتاجون ايضا
للدعم الامداد الطبي والمعينات
شكرا جزيلا لهذه المداخله دكتوره هبه عمر
شكرا لوجودك معنا رئيس اللجنه التمهيه
التمهيديه في لجنه الاطباء